hi I'm Erik Bosse and Avengers infinity
Wars ending was definitely the most
striking thing about it but wouldn't you
know it the darn thing almost went a
totally different way somehow even
darker way recent interviews with a
visual effects artist of the movie
revealed an alternate version of Thanos
his brief reunion with young Gamora
after the snap and apparently the visual
details of the scene were among the most
debated among the creative team during
the production process so let us talk
about this infinity war alternate ending
and you can breathe a sigh of relief it
isn't one where all the Avengers die
that'll be in Avengers 4 and real quick
before you begin this video was brought
to you by Squarespace whether you need a
domain or website or online store make
it with Squarespace more details on that
later okay an interview with Marvel's
visual effects supervisor and a head
artist from Digital Domain of the
effects company that works on a lot of
these huge movies went deep into the
design of Thanos and how they captured
Josh Brolin's performance and when asked
which Thanos scenes changed the most
during the production process they
revealed this interesting tidbit just
after he snaps his fingers what that
world with little Gamora how that should
be represented so we went through sort
of an exploratory phase with that one so
you know looking at different options
and what does that mean so he's
referring to thanasis reunion with young
Gamora in this other realm a place we
later learn from the directors was
inside the soul stone thus it's orange
color now we're still figuring out
exactly what happened in this moment but
the figurative interpretation is that
Thanos upon wiping out half the universe
himself faces the emotional price that
he paid to achieve this goal sacrificing
his daughter like a jerk but according
to this interview that interpretation
was originally going to be way darker
one of the early ideas was to have him
walking on a river of blood intended to
represent the blood of his victims whoa
this rejected concept isn't just extreme
it actually would have tied together
Thanos his journey in a really
interesting way and the fact that this
image was part of the DNA of the artists
creative process reveals a deeper
meaning behind the character so for one
the river of blood echoes a subtle
moment of setup earlier in the film when
black panther confronts the black order
outside Wakanda and he made this
interesting promise
danos would have nothing but dust and
blood ironically thanasis victory did
grant him dust as half of all life
turned into it including two Tala and
this ultimate ending would have given
Thanos equal amounts of blood as he
walks on a river of it but this image to
Thanos also gives some spiritual
significance to his victory something
the directors have hinted at in
interviews describing Thanos as a holy
warrior at the end of the movie a river
of blood is a very powerful image that
alludes to the Old Testament of the
Bible if you remember your Sunday School
teachings in the book of Exodus the
Pharaoh refuses to free the Hebrews for
Moses so God smites Egypt with ten
plagues the first of which was to turn
the Nile into a river of blood
interestingly the last of these plagues
was the death of every Egyptian
firstborn son kind of a revenge from the
Egyptians past move to kill all male
Hebrew children that were born which is
why Moses had to be put into a basket
see back in those days God pick sides
this kind of genocide for the greater
good is exactly what Thanos does he'd
used himself as a wiser deity trying to
save the universe from itself willing to
smite half of them to teach the other
half a lesson and speaking of biblical
references it's interesting that Thanos
walks on top of the surface of this
River famously walking on water was a
miracle performed by Jesus in the New
Testament
so Thanos repeating this kind of miracle
in a way couldn't paint him as a
sacrificial figure at least in his own
eyes like there's been a lot of
speculation that thanasis visit with
gomorrah in the soul stone represents
his actual death as a result of his own
snap and if this is true it suggests
that Thanos in this moment truly
sacrificed his own life in order to as
he sees it save humanity and all the
other T's across the universe no I'm not
calling Thanos space Jesus that would be
crazy
space Jesus is Adam warlock get it right
a question for you guys what a river of
blood have made Thanos's win more
powerful emotionally speaking for you
comment down below with your thoughts
and as I mentioned before this video was
brought to you by Squarespace
if you want to set up a super stylish
website fast you can make it with
Squarespace whether it's to set up a
business showcase some of your creative
work or share some travel photos from
your trip to a creepy after
life realm somebody's gonna want to see
that Squarespace is eight new templates
of 2018 and they look so nice and you
don't have to know anything about coding
or design they take care of all of it
for you just go to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to Squarespace comm slash new
rockstars to get 10% off your first
purchase or click on the link in the
description and remember to follow me on
Twitter and Instagram Eddie a vos for
projects I got in store for you guys
like this video share it around
subscribe to new rockstars to learn how
all your favorite movies were actually a
lot more terrifying originally for
example check out this early cut of the
famous elevator fight scene in Captain
America Winter Soldier I like the old
version better by